good morning gamers it's minecraft
everyday is minecraft day yay
I was literally gonna pull it record
another game and then I was like I just
want to play minecraft isn't that right
Sven oh my god yes of course of course
Sven get off the meadowlands you crazy
look at the glorious IKEA Tower it's a
glorious new day what are we going to do
today's event don't go in the boat I
swear to God everyone kept saying how
rare these are I'm like I don't know
what you're talking about
people are saying one of these is uragan
that's impossible don't you dare say
that spend why I literally just okay if
there's one Sven
please get out of the Bott all right if
there's one thing I feel like we haven't
done its the nether okay I feel like if
we have not found a single freaking
thing in the nether what's up with that
I'm gonna make my you know what I'll
make two pickaxes that's right I'm crazy
and now we can enchant them because I
have epic bookcases requires level 30
efficiency for a WOD how do I get in
fishes before Oh level 17 I'm gonna
level up to level 17 be right back it's
bad are you okay see
okay we're level 17
listen I may be of Minecraft veteran but
I don't know all these new hip emoji
bursts you know what I'm saying
17 efficiency 3 my god it's gonna be the
most powerful pickaxe ever pick hey look
look I got a I got a tyrant shovel
efficiency 3 and he blew my mind let me
show you I was mining out this sand
right normal okay pretty bad
and then you whip out your level 3 and
you're just like it's so fast look at it
it's so fast it took
can you imagine level 4 can you imagine
level 4 oh my gosh alright we're gonna
explore the nether and we're gonna find
epic loot isn't that right you can't
come to my house no you can't okay fine
you can go
nevermind okay fine you all right just
don't fall down
just don't fall down that would be
really bad if you fold down just don't
just don't fold down just
you're crazy just don't pull down just
careful so you don't fall down oh damn
it careful so you don't fall down pig oh
god no oh god no oh resting pork chops
good joke Billy all right I know you can
find coal stuck
I know you can find cool stuff I will
find cool stuff Oh Ricky we haven't
tried our pickaxe level three all right
let's try gamers
nothing can stop a man when he's got a
pickaxe level three everyone knows that
oh my god oh my god don't fall it's time
that we dig SAP under man another kill
kill kill time pre ender listen nothing
personal but you have to keep oh don't
hit me Swedish I have the power of God
and IKEA on my side oh god he's got the
skills what this critic attack crit
attack great the tanks what are you
gonna do you're not even gonna fight me
coward
you're a coward
no nether all right you can stop looking
stop you could suffer good stop all
right let's go sicko mode watch this
gamers watch this level 3 dude can you
imagine level 4 owl all right we're
gonna level up to level 4 it's gonna be
epic
alright let's just dig this way oh I
don't even have to do this it's just so
cool
oh god it's burning out really fast
uh-huh that sucks
I can't repair it it's fine I'm just
kidding okay well yeah we're just like
out here we're digging I'm having a good
time it's the nether so I need to find
these blaze guys this Snoop Doggy Dogg's
because I need like fire rod from them
or something I have not seen a single
one damn that's a lot of lava
I have literally knots in a single one
what's happening mr. Piggy these are
really good for leveling up and I'm
saving them up because I want to build a
special structure later foreshadowing
foreshadowing foreshadowing what is he
gonna build Felix I don't know I'm not
gonna say I'm not gonna sing I'll
whisper it to piggy god I wish spent
could be here he could like attack the
pigs it could be a good time we could
all just like hang out that's just what
I think there's too many of them I can't
be bothered to get all of them Gorge
but they're everywhere and i need the x
speed level 30 Felix think about level
think about level three diamond pickaxe
all my gold Jay belieber jeeva liebe
first rule of Minecraft Felix never
forget it it's just it's too strong it's
too strong my pickaxe is too strong I
can't help what
what what is this pigs explain this this
is your house what is this whoa what
whoa whoa we couldn't whoa whoa what is
that
better go that oh it's like a fortress
can i oh I can mine it alright alright
gamers we finally found something but
what is this thing
it looks like an evil fortress Oh new
recipe what is this nether bricks that's
what I poop out every day all right I
need more brightness I can't freaking
see anything anymore it's still dark in
the nether maybe I can turn on my lights
oh love it okay gamers
whoa what is that let's not get lost
because if we get lost your goodness and
spiders gonna be super sad looks like a
bridge got it a bridge oh god it's a
furniture anything but a page damn I
finally uh it of course it's it goes to
nothing cool good bridge good joke guys
thanks much
thanks a notch it was his idea
there's something up there there's
definitely something up there it's got
all kinds of colors and stuff piggy what
this that I wasn't actually speaking all
right so whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
I think we're entering something here
all right so I got a tip from this guy
who made a youtube video and he said it
was called tips for PewDiePie and he
said place the torches on one side when
you enter so you know which way is out
and I'm like oh my god I can't believe I
never thought of that
gamers helping gamers Oh what is this
it's a lava pool
I can drink from it what is this oh my
god what sorry huh what is that up
thanks a blaze guys I need to kill them
okay careful Felix careful Kippur don't
get ahead of yourself
think about I need these four potion
brewing I think give me potion brewing
I'm gonna make potion oh they grow on
the soul sand why didn't no one tell me
okay let's kill them I have my milk I
have my milk I'm ready
well they fly a car they shoot the do
sir I'm out
I'm minecraft out bike me coward out god
I'm a cursed what does that do what does
that do what does that do I don't know
what that do i I'm dying I think Oh God
Kiva liebe it scares me cuz I don't know
what I'm scared of you know what I mean
alright we're fine we killed bone dude
already got coal what is it
miner loser alright blaze guy place guy
I got some blazing to do breezy
I need your rod that sounds so wrong
whoa blaze guy come here fight me coward
wait do I have arrows
I have arrows do I have a bow of course
not why would I carry a bow dump alright
fine
Felix don't forget about your little
trick about the okay alright cool
all right we'll do this we'll do this
this goes oh there he is
he was close hey schmuck I'll fight you
to death
goddamn cotton bottom did we get it did
he drop it damn it did you not drop it
seriously it's gonna be okay Felix just
focus on the gold
what is the gold again I don't know I
don't know nether bricks late Oh God
okay come here and fight me coward all
right can I get over there I can all
right I wish you didn't do that coward
you're a coward and a scoundrel
num-num num-num did he drop it
did he drop it damn it I need it before
I can make potions so I can make
awesomeness I can make awesome sauce
isn't that right Tobuscus fans what's
over there there's a spawner there it's
a spoiler
I found this father hey Pig look at the
spoiler for me I will remember where it
is all right let's get the mushrooms
let's get the mushrooms I don't need a
shovel together okay more mushroom we're
gonna make potions we're gonna slurp
them and we're gonna we're just gonna
slurp slurp game smash like the test oh
my god what can we find diamonds more
diamonds question mark alright let's
ditch all this stuff oh my god they're
gonna get so pissed off when they
realize I took their stuff alright okay
another one
what is this birthday time this nether
splash no one told me why didn't
literally no one tell me about the
nether here I am mining aah
fight them like man Felix
there's more than I bargained for us
that's more than I bargained for
jump attack jump attack jump attack so
what does he do it makes my heart black
so I can't really see my hell all right
come here cowards all right will spawn
the skillet well I mean where whatever
it's called I've gone listen I'm a
veteran
I get veteran jump attack jump attack
jump attack eat
alright Blazers well Blazers go back to
Russia cowards
got'em Jess Jess it dropped yes we're
gonna blaze it what up losers what is
this just a wall you just put walls in
your house dumb dummy dumb on a
stomachache I'm so stressed Oh God come
on okay there was a spawn there
somewhere okay so which way is the way
out okay so let's do it like okay I came
up with new system
Dumbledore means the way out okay double
doors the way out
got it gamers I'm a little low on food
I'm a little scared but this is epic
alright well close up will close up the
places that we has a dead end if this
was a waste of time notch she thanks for
nothing not God here I was thinking
notch was a gamer and then this happens
waste my goddamn time not there's a
terrace that's beautiful
okay that looks very dangerous all right
so this is where we came from
I don't like these guys hi-yah you can't
hit me on Swedish eat no what did I say
first rule of Minecraft
you broke it okay we're going beep oh
God
oh there's a lot of lots of gamers here
go back to Sweden oh he didn't like that
alright alright listen I know this is
kind of mean but I'm gonna have to close
you up I don't like you you're not a
blazer I want more chest
give me more diamonds I want money give
me your money your money and your
children I want to eat them I'm not
asking for a lot here oh my god oh my
minecraft listen don't shoot oh shoot oh
shoot
are you not listening are you not paying
attention well now you're a goner Oh God
- in the road to neuro
all this is stairs I fell down the
stairs oh my god I thought I fell down
in lava I thought I was a goner I can't
do this anymore
bye blaze us okay we got to blaze rods
this is good this is good good
oh there's another one that hated loot
go away go wait Blazers yeah
oh you're your own poo pee pee pee poo
pee pee bee Oh God heel heel heel Felix
don't get greedy don't get greedy no my
mum cha-cha cha-cha Jojo
oh yeah back in action you thought I ran
while I ran from don't run into the
fryer Philip
yeah can't spawn out can ya can't spawn
now oh okay they can still they can
still spawn for that that's fine
only cowards all right you know what on
second thought on second thought I have
to I have two things left so I think
this is it stop Felix focus focus focus
focus focus focus all right
I am sweating profusely
oh god it's over it's over gamers no
blazes they keep spawning I'm not afraid
okay look the mining trick help we found
our way out and it was easy
back to sent back to spent back to
Jurgen back to spin back to me alright
alright we've been pretty bad when I
come from hey pigs gee thanks a lot for
the help
oh I pushed your cousin down the lava
well how am I supposed to know he can't
swim alright where's my home it's by the
glow stones where's my home there it is
thank you
we're gonna make potions gamers we're
gonna make freaking potions and we're
gonna sell our bug and it's gonna be big
baby I wish I had that for the water
temple and that I struggles so much with
because I hadn't I didn't have the blaze
rods Oh what if we do a temple now also
now we can make the eye of ender and we
can actually find the ender dragon oh my
god we are getting close gamers we
started sleeping in the nether
now we rule the nether
that's what I'm talking about you're
diggin it roots epic don't talk to me
God
Sven come in here let's talk I don't
want to talk in front of them I don't
want to talk it from the water she
please thank me oh god oh god okay fine
geo look I made a table I know I know my
place is sweet let's go to sleep that
was an epic journey
damn there's so many things to do in
Minecraft I'm freaking out dude level
what level am i 22 oh my god dude spend
when we're level 3000 boy don't get me
started gamer we found diamonds that's
right that's right diamonds why don't I
use my diamonds to actually make stuff
don't be ridiculous
then some Spa hum [ __ ] as we say in
London spend listen it was epic I found
this castle and I raided it and we got
the lot of gamer loot like they're gonna
be so pissed spend spent get down from
there get get down from there right now
spend you do not you do not belong there
I don't care that it warms your feet
careful you don't even have feet
it's just nether wart
that's disgusting alright then come in
come in we got to make potions stop
we're gonna make dude we're gonna drink
stuff hey come on we're gonna make slurp
juice come on alright so how do I make a
potion rack what place power mod oh it's
not called a potion stand it's called
brewing stand there it is gamers all
right we need cobblestone then do you
have some extra I know you can't carry
stuff I'm literally just can you stop
going there you're scaring me you're
scaring their minecraft kids brew eggs
then
and we got a Bruin stand and and I got a
spot for it doesn't really look good no
are you kidding me it I can't
high-waisted it oh all right fine
sorry saying I know the nine year olds
are getting ad mad that just happened
but I didn't know I was I supposed to
know because we put it there now it's a
brilliance bag
cool now we put Bruin stand he doesn't
make any sense
I know okay okay I got a givers see
alright I know I think it's bad
please you need to chill you need to
have some milk can he drink milk
hey son you want some titty meat abuse
oh yeah that's right he came right away
[Music]
there you go okay so problem right it's
going up there makes no sense the
problem solution nice I have an axe I
didn't know you forgot so mad when I I
use my hands for certain things that I
can use in tool spend it for the love of
smell stop at the love of year again
stop that alright cool little extra
bridge will change the color later I'm
in our lifetime there you go alright
that looks at me yeah I'm getting the
right color spend I know the nine year
olds will get annoyed if it isn't the
right color plus I'm annoyed too but we
have a lot of stuff to do not to worry
about exact same right now new yawns of
freaking colors okay sleep slope spin is
a chop now we can make brewing stuff I
bought bucket of puffer fish because
those are the ones to make you breathe
on the water and I think you guys told
me that my respiration helmet no its
blast protection everyone was like oh
it's in your chest
no it is Oh any vials wait how do I do
this I can make fire resistance water
breathing night-vision with the golden
carrot I can buy those super cheap
because I'm rich thick potion damn all
right turtle shell
ocean of turtle master what does that do
gasps tears pushing regeneration okay so
first we need a water bottle made out of
three glasses
the worst when we have glasses just like
we got nothing else all right let's make
some vials let's make some extra I guess
we got to fill them with water what it
says minecraft how you doing today boat
count boat Cal let me drink some of your
titty juice
oh thanks both Cal you're the best or
the bottle of gold oh it's right there
bleep oh god I gotta save them what do I
throw away
Oh Cole I don't think I need one Oh
complaining right you can go to spend
please
it's dangerous here all right maybe I
should empty my inventory love it okay
so I've literally never done this before
and everyone was cringing when I try to
figure out the enchantment table listen
I'm the first one doing this okay I need
the blaze rod Frick blaze rod I think
you just do this boom boom okay I get
four out of that how am i holding fire
explain that scientists all right it's
happening it's happening it's happening
dude we're doing science here span
that's right why are these red when
clearly these are blue okay not you
freaked up on this one right then what
that sounds like it's brewed awkward
potion no effects okay so now we have
three awkward potions huh relatable I'm
awkward relatable so now we combine with
the pufferfish
oh god this feels really mean right I
can't do this right I can't just put a
poke my seal of his porridge fishes -
she's gonna get so mad how do I get four
ones I want to get the thing out of the
bucket
Oh God that was a bad idea was it stop
it then stop it slender so sleep sit sit
sit
all right all right don't panic don't
panic
okay I'm dying in my own house bye
No okay okay cool oh I thought Sven
would attack it I got so scared
all right cool so I guess that's one way
to get it
I'm sorry puffer I'm sorry you died okay
so now I think I combine awkward potion
with puffer fish and redstone so I make
it with redstone instead of blaze power
is that correct listen the instructions
aren't very clear I'm just gonna try it
Swedish man discovers dynamite 1984
colorized okay that clearly doesn't go
there what about here I can't put it
there
did I not close my door gosh get out of
my house spider okay what if I just
awkward potion and puffer fish
I feel bad dude you know what let's put
more awkward potions is this gonna work
Sven yes Oh blue potion of water
breathing it worked it worked we
invented science oh that would be so
freaking proud dude I bet he's crying
right now okay well that was a lot
easier than I thought
why oh yeah I can extend it to eight
minutes with redstone so if I do flip
mm-hmm okay okay hopefully I don't freak
this up all right did it work eight
minutes I'm a freaking genius where's my
Minecraft award okay let's put a barrel
there so I can put all my potions stop
next to it that's cool right yeah that's
definitely epic how do I make a parallel
game now we can put all art want it okay
so we can put all our potions stuff here
dude I'm getting good at Minecraft you
can't you can't lie so I got to get
these puffer fascias out some huh
god I don't want to do that again Oh
Frick the water alright let's just let's
just do it outside this time we stood
here ah I'm sorry you're so cute I'm so
sorry I changed my mind
I changed my mind I changed my mind you
live your live you can stay I have 3
potions that's I I feel I feel bad
some people just belong in buckets
alright so what other stuff we can do
I think night vision would be cool
potion of invisibility witch spider I
what Oh the potion of healing if I do
the glistering melon I can buy all this
stuff dude I'm rich let's go I'm going
on a shopping sin
the are free can be it's shopping time
alright you're gonna see you in a bit
buddy you I want to build a torture
chamber for yep would be a future
project okay so I think it's this way
I'm so glad we found that nether place
that really makes my life so much better
I thought potions seems so crazy I'm
like how am I gonna get all these items
isn't that right piggy like I don't have
money I mean I do have a lot of okay
nevermind who attacked my place don't
attack my place alright Matt man you
finally yeah I'll sell my paper without
all the paper I brought I have way more
gosh I have more paper okay
sorry guys sorry I'm back I just need a
paper paper guy coming through I'm not
even gonna ask what you guys are doing
matter who you love I don't discriminate
do what you want pick people alright I'm
here for this paper and the money
because if I level this guy up people
treat me better maps and more maps means
more epic minecraft adventures and I
think that's really all that matters in
Minecraft okay I got a little I keep
buying my paper is the finest quality
Swedish paper its Scandinavian design
pick I literally don't have my paper are
you kidding me does he level of if I buy
stuff oh my god it hurts I don't want to
buy this crud he buys glass this guy
breaks glass I'll talk to him later oh
my god kitty so apparently I've been
trying to feed the cat cooked fish sorry
apparently number one rule of Minecraft
is that cats eat raw fish is it worth
setting up like a rail system in another
so I can travel faster that makes sense
right
you're okay there oh no no okay these
guys sells glistering melon three of
them and golden carrots
I guess I'll buy some cuz then we can
make potion of Aleen okay that that
doesn't sound that good I'm sure we'll
need it for the ender dragon or
something like that if we add a spider
eye or something else to potion of
healing it becomes portion of farming
what does that do
only the golden carrot we do night
vision night vision we do need because
I'm gonna do it more water temples and I
want to do it improperly next time maybe
next episode I don't know I need to make
paper you make paper out of these for
some reason oh god I'm full I'm always
full can they not make backpacks for
this game you can make little potions
that will make you invisible but a
backpack that
too much to ask large hey son how you
doing right actually not I don't have
more paper I'm like broke on paper I do
have a lot of these stuff hold on I need
to sort out my inventory what is wrong
with me I'm making paper that's what I'm
doing mom you don't understand but I'm
making paper mom which I'm gonna sell to
the trade smell and then I'm gonna maybe
he will sell me a map mom
I can make sure girl what oh yeah I can
make potions out of sugar what can I
make out of sugar I can make I can make
swiftness I'll make us I'll make a swift
now let's make some sugar let's make
some sugar baby
all right Sven I'm going on another
business trip why would I make a potion
of slowness oh wait I have an idea so
now if we put sugar there it's gonna
make us faster okay epic and then if we
had glowstone dust it will make us not
just 20% faster but 40% faster dude
we're gonna be so fast
Sven you don't understand you don't
understand how fast I'm gonna go this is
epic all right I'm gonna make the
fastest business deals on the planet son
I think I'm running out of inventory
already maybe I'll remove that one okay
spend time for more business deals be
right back don't look at me all right no
okay no railroad required well let me
let me go to a good spot okay here we go
here we go let's select Freight how do I
drink it I never drank a portion before
okay we're fast gotta go fast damn son
this is awesome
yes oh god I'm losing speed I need the
speed of momentum first we're gonna sell
these dumb Schmucks my pumpkins a
Schmucks you want some pumpkins goddamn
right you want some pumpkin ah
where's the other one you want my
pumpkins my pumpkins he's already out of
stock are you kidding me I just waste a
potion how long his alliance does it not
say a timer
god I'm so fast oh yeah you guys told me
they there's stuff underneath the belts
but I never believed it oh there's
definitely something there
damn this I'm so easily entertained
there's nothing here you guys keep lying
to me keep lying to a gamer and see what
happens
all right slope number two okay that's
annoying all right we got to sell the
paper oh god I forgot the glass
I forgot the glass Felix I have the
memory of a puffer fish no problem I got
the potion oh yeah oh ha I'm fast pigs
are like is that a bird is it a plane
oh no it's Swedish boy running very fast
good one Felix alright I'm back from
business trip but don't worry I'm just
here for one thing and one thing only
yes I would do it what kind of drugs did
I just take I think if anything I'll use
I'll use a 20% because that one lasts in
eight minutes why am i talking about
that oldest
so there's something cool underneath the
bill I freaked you guys I freaked you
all all right Matt guy you're not math
guy where's map guy your map guy was of
glass yes okay so now he'll level up
next time hey you want some of this
I'll sell you that too oh you're out of
stock that's just too sad okay epic so
now he can sell us a let other stuff but
we have to wait it's ok it's ok it's ok
it's ok it's ok we have other stuff to
do it's fine I'm fine with it it's fine
just teleport what's happening oh it's
making me dizzy just go through you're
making me sick
thank you oh god I'm so slow now it's
painful this is awful
I think that was a pretty successful
business trip thanks man
I made some stone eels no I didn't buy
you a gift
sorry Sven jeez not everything is about
you I know I know my business
Oh miss Bella is quite here I think I
put it down that Bell means business I'm
gonna make another barrel because I want
it to look pretty in my house sorry sue
me sue me sue me oh yeah I need to make
the underwater one which you make with
the golden carrot then we're almost
level 30 oh my god same level 30 I know
do I love love from doing brewing stuff
night vision and I can extend in with
the red stars I love this this is cool
such a cool update all right while we
wait for the potion let's pay our
respect
almost done there it is 8 minutes that's
a long time that's a lot of slurping
okay so we're ready
next time we go now what I really want
to do is I want to build another house
and no I don't have to but I want to and
I also want to build a torture chamber
for you maybe like in here we could put
like give me some ideas for torture
chamber for yep
what does that do it does that do
anything maybe we can put it next to
yeah band oh yeah that's good I like
that
hey yep this is annoying to you does
that annoy you is it annoying I hope
you're annoyed yeah because no one likes
you and this is hot
this is what it's like talking to you
yet this is what it's like being around
you really really annoying
cuz that's what you are you hear me look
at me
God is just no way to get through to you
is it no way I'm trying to be nice I'm
trying to be a friend and this is how
you treat me I give you home I give you
life I feed you sometimes I give you new
cool skills what do I get back
nothing nothing I know I know
both cow excuse me that was my whatsapp
okay so let's go to the other side
because I'm gonna build a summer house
oh my god there's turtle here turtle how
do you get here
so apparently you don't have to kill the
turtles I know it's awesome right I
think I need to just oh my god level
three I just need to find another one do
you have a friend any hot chicks that
you you like
listen I can't breed you with nothing
surely there's other girls around here
right there's no one you got no one
I'll find you a girlfriend turtle I've
got to find a girlfriend because then we
can breed them and then we can make the
helmet that's how you make the helmet
you don't kill actually kill them I
swear there used to be a turtle here a
mr. toe perhaps I'll see we perfect we
need this for turtle okay this is this
isn't working
I swear they used to be turtle 50,000
terminals used to live here now it's a
ghost town get that reference only
gamers all right how do I find you a
mate I need to find someone for turtle
to frick oh dude three Enderman all
right it's game on sweet dad
you can't hurt me okay maybe pin yes a
pearl epic oh god I hate the tiny one so
annoying you're snowing oh oh I I hate I
don't like stop moving everyone stop
moving I need to get the other ones I
need to kick English I don't have time
for Sam oh great he gave me the food
stand all right let's get the other one
Oh where's the titty milk when you need
it my shield is almost down across well
is that an infected villager what that's
awesome
cuz everything has to be here alright my
my shield is almost down but I'm down
I'm down eat
eat eat there you go any pearl that was
a third one go Coney in that sky in
there matzo endo jisang we didn't find a
part we gotta find a girl I'm your the
wing man of this turtle I'm gonna find
him there you are there you are there
you are smash like if you're a gamer
oh god I'm actually really long no I
don't want to lose my level
I don't know she'll I don't have a
shield and this is over let's go gamers
I'll find your girlfriend one day I
swear but I have to bounce uh-oh
back to sleep at this we did oh no I
lost my shield thank you virgin turtle
we're gonna we're gonna get up we're
gonna get him to enderpearls I think
this means I have 12 and I think I
actually need 12 but then again to find
the place I need one more what am I
talking about well you basically let me
see if this is correct I think I can
make an eye of ender now I owe
that's when I can make an ender chest
now as well which which is like a portal
chest okay so I think you just throw it
up somewhere and you see which way it
goes and that the way it goes is where
the portal to the ender thing is where
did it go there it is so it's that way
whoa okay let's remember that so that
way is that the way to the ender portal
but we're not gonna do that now we're
not gonna do that now okay I think
that's it for today's episode is a night
Reisman next time we got a lot of stuff
to do and I need to stock up on some
ayran and all that stuff which you don't
need to watch smash like for more
minecraft for the episode if you enjoy
all the support has been just absolutely
insane isn't that right Sven